all right so Hamas calls for a day of
Rage in March is followed by heightened
security across the globe that followed
quickly where is all of this headed
Victor Davis Hansen is a senior fellow
at the Hoover institution he joins us
now to answer Victor you're always great
at putting this into perspective where
are we
headed well I think Israel was at the
height of its Prosperity security it's a
model of a Humane successful society and
there were all these centrifugal forces
around it people said if you just hire
Gins and bring them into your uh work
force every day they will see how
magnanimous you are and they will
interpret that in re reciprocal they
will they will appreciate it you will
help the economy and they said if you're
going to have the Abram Accords renewed
it's going to be a new day and don't
worry about the Iran deal we'll uh we'll
negotiate and we have Robert Mali
working on it and we're going to bring
uh Aid back to Hamas and that was all
fine and good the pressures that Israel
was under but as you said they didn't
read the charter of Hamas and Hamas has
never said that they were interested in
any type of deal with Israel much less
they've even said they don't even want
to build a model state in Gaza even
though they've had millions of dollars
infused from the Europeans the Americans
the UN they're not interested in that
just read what they say they want to
destroy Israel and Israel has no margin
of error well so when you pressure it
and pressure it and they feel that maybe
just maybe just at this moment finally
at the Apex of our success we can be
magnanimous and we can live and then and
that can't happen not until hos is gone
because it has it's an existential
threat they want to destroy it and
what's very scary is we in the United
States think if you have a PhD or an MA
or JD and you have a university Billet
or you're the head of a foundation you
drive an MB mbw M it Mercedes you name
it that somehow you're sophisticated and
when you you say that you're for homas
or Israel's aparte there's no connection
with the violence you wouldn't but
you're advocating violence they are
advocating when they say they want want
to destroy Israel here in the United
States He sophisticated they do and
they're complicit with it and when you
see people beheaded and dismembered and
their bodies mutilated and necklaced and
then you have these refined
intellectuals saying that this was great
that's that's what they're saying and we
all say well they don't really mean that
they're just saying that the give the
pal Palestinians a state well the Hamas
doesn't want one Gaza doesn't want one
so even where I work at Stanford
University we had a professor was just
suspended because she was centering on
Palestinian uh Jewish students and
trying to ostracize them in our own
class it's Insidious and they get away
with it and I think what's needed is
Israel is going to have to say we're not
at the end of history and and don't
pressure us we're a Humane Society we
have nothing to apologize for and we're
going to take care care of a moss and we
we don't want we didn't ask for it you
you pressured us we tried the
therapeutic route and now we're going to
go through the tragic route that they
want to destroy us and we're not going
to let them do it and when we we all of
us in the United States have to say
every time you get up and you support
Hamas you're supporting murder and we
don't care what your title is how much
money you have what the coat and tie and
the suit you wear that's what you're
doing you're no different than the
people who go across and butcher
civilians in a time of Peace at a
Holiday so we've got to change the
entire Dynamic and we've got to stop
telling Israel what Israel has to do
because if anything goes wrong we don't
suffer they do and anybody who read
hamas's Charter anybody listened to
Robert Mali or Iran Point man and said
what he said about Hamas and Hezbollah
the last few years anybody that takes
the words of Anthony blinkin when he
says that Iran may not have any uh
connection with this Terror or that we
should have a cease fight all of that
has to be put in the proper contract
that is partly responsible to what we're
watching so let's just lay off Israel
and don't tell it what to do when it's
suffered 12,000 deaths in a premodern
pre-vis fashion will that we haven't
seen in our lifetime we've seen nothing
like this it's just pure hate and if
they had their chance they would do it
to every Jewish citizen of Israel I'm
getting so tired of these modern
intellectuals intelligencia that think
that because they're refined they can
they can endorse barbarism and nobody
will call them out on it Victor you
mentioned that Outland story out of
Stanford we're going to be talking more
about that in just a moment we
appreciate you being with us hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else